hey everybody it's me and today I'm here
with its Marcy everybody its Marcy hey
everybody today we're playing over cut
device game about teamwork and
friendship fist bump for friendship yeah
alright I'm gonna be grandma this is a
game about cooking
grandma I'm kinda saving in a tree best
friends forever
can't you see if you play overcook and
you don't get overcook and if you don't
get three stars you might as well
consider yourself not as a gamer
mm-hm okay so we have to make dumplings
right is that a sushi and dumpling we
have to work it out together as we okay
all right here we go everybody
grandma first order okay now we have to
work together you prepare the flour
prepare the flour and then our
compressive strength we cut it together
[Music]
this is just listen to everything I say
yeah did you work on the fishy yeah
you got a steam it you soup raw fish
this is sushi all right serving the meal
we did it fist bump epic style sorry
don't tell me move Kara chop some
carrots this is just like that long time
[Music]
what you did with the flour kind of
dumplings are you making steamed it
[Music]
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
oh God
masya never give up wait don't go go go
go
it's not stayin
what no three stars this time I'm taking
charge you see I'm in front of me you
listen to me okay you tell me what to do
and I will do it like a proper sweet you
actually yes
what do I do
I do the carry you to me forgive me oh
you do the carry
what are you doing you seem right away
yes I never told you yes yeah you put
two flowers they are ours and this is so
frustrating the wedding is over Marcia
their wedding listen to me now
what do I do chop chopping the meat sir
yes ma'am
that meat is chop man was the fire what
do I do now ma'am let's start with the
flour and then I grab a shrimp no chop
that shirt and now water like you this
the flour mix with the shrimp and
[Music]
what happened what happened what
happened maritza what about that what do
i do what do i do much yeah what do i do
what is happening get out of my way sir
sir get out of my way this is a kitchen
not a museum no left are left on prep
the left one
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin what are you going up north cuz
that's where that rainbow level all
right we gotta throw some together
alright so throw me just throw me much
stuff too strong here
more I was awesome more you're doing
great that's how you sound like you mean
spaghetti
how would you need a chop I got I got
your head all right forget forget
mushroom I said mushroom
Gavin Tager yeah I need a plate
I need a plane stop throwing stuff and
you like what are you doing give it a
flag sir Sir oh yeah 20 bro hit
you said yes to marrying me
all right meats comin up meats coming up
meats coming I'm cooking to me you like
it there cook the rice the rice put the
rice cook it with you actually serve raw
but I need to give it I need mushrooms
you throw it
oh I catch it did you see that replay I
got hit by the Rye days did it like do
no wrong in the rice
now I'm holding the dish of you either
way no no no five stars do it with me
it's a new format
maybe games don't rip this off I swear
the guy
[Music]
it's chubby Marzian you how would you
excuse me excuse me if you were falling
I be your wings okay let's go epic style
right I got the rush yes I got take the
second one who's gonna get it first huh
who's gonna get it first
Oh what are you doing the same what are
you doing let it go okay
alright come on no no jokes rice you
take the chicken I take your chicken
[ __ ]
Oh Deborah God Israel did you see that
[Music]
ah
however this marathon good did we have a
chicken reality I don't know this was
epic smash like if you enjoy over a cut
and if you are hungry right now
mm subscribe for more epic videos this
is Ben
[Music]